was the murder weapon found at OJ's home
only I talked to Marcia Clark today
Marcia a knife apparently was found at
the Rockingham estate when it was
demolished what's your initial reaction
to this revelation it's a remarkable
development if it does turn out to be
connected to the murders of Ron and
Nicole I just hope the truth comes out
about this situation
ét today exclusive with Marcia Clark
the lead prosecutor in Simpson's murder
trial finds it all of bit baffling it
might be a hoax it might be somebody who
planted it and then just pretended to
find it the knife is just the latest
twist into the unsolved 22 year old
murders of OJ's ex Nicole Brown Simpson
and her friend Ron Goldman the house
here on what was once a Jays property
was demolished back in 1998 and police
say it's possible that's when the knife
was discovered the finder of the knife
apparently turned it over to an officer
who was working as a security officer
during production of a movie and police
say he held on to it until very recently
within the last month
LAPD became aware of an item that item
has been recovered by Robbery Homicide
investigators it is being treated as we
would all evidence do you think that
there still could be DNA on that knife
it's very possible I mean they recovered
DNA on mummies in Egypt so it's entirely
possible that if if there is some DNA to
be recovered that it could be found
especially with today's technology which
is much more sensitive Orrin Thal James
Simpson not guilty of the crime of
murder Simpson was acquitted in a trial
that lasted more than eight months but
could he be tried again the likelihood
of any prosecution stemming from this
evidence very very very slim so you know
but but it would be you know but we have
to find out what this means
Clark's role in the case has been back
in the news after the success of the FX
series the People vs OJ Simpson
he can't hide forever
Clark has played brilliantly by Sarah
Paulson and it's been the number one
show on cable on Tuesday nights is it
ironic that this comes up now with the
spotlight being shined on the case again
because of the television show it really
is a bizarre coincidence
it is completely strange I have heard
that the reason that he this person who
had the knife thought of calling the
police department is because of the
series next OJ's lost interview today
and a lot of elements of you know
attractive people well-known celebrity
money sex appeal Oh Jay takes on the
media in an exclusive just uncovered
interview with to Pepperdine students
Tommy Lee and Mindy Thomas it was shot
in 1997 on his Rockingham estate after
he was found not guilty
I thought the media let the American
public as well as myself down as well as
Nicole and Ron down and trying to find
the true perpetrators and I just thought
it became such a moneymaker for the
tabloids and a lot of people got rich
you know virtually every participate
except me